thank you it's a it's a pleasure to be
here and
the first slide up here when leslie
invited me here she she said oh we're
going to meet at gates hall
and the lecture is going to be at gates
hall immediately this picture popped
into my mind i'm an architect
this is gates hall at cornell university
the brand new building
and
the second slide is
i'm an architect i graduated from
cornell in architecture
and
the
college at cornell there's a full
college of architecture art and planning
and architects we work with engineers
all the time in fact we love engineers
because you guys do a huge amount of
work for us
and we get to design buildings and work
with with engineers
and
it was a so i'm used to
going to cornell i was very used to
interacting with with engineers and when
when i went there one of the main topics
yes we you know earth day and all of
that was starting but one of the main
topics was was computerized graphics
and one of my early experiences
was the the formative um
computerized graphics were were jointly
developed or partially jointly developed
at cornell and in the architecture
school and in the engineering school and
it's a collaborative
uh event and that's when i really
learned the value of engineers
so
now now we're going to go to a slightly
different view of of climate change
the
how many of you taken an art history
class anybody
oh yes thank yes
good
the if you if you take an art history
class you you look at things
in a different lens and that's what i'm
going to try and go through in these
next few slides this is a slide of the
mediterranean these are three ancient
ruin sites
leptus magna ephesus and curion has
anybody been to any of these sites
anybody seen pictures of any of these
sites okay good
good
the
um
the issue is is that the mediterranean
in climate sense has radically changed
in the last 2000 years
there's lots of reasons why
but we don't really know
there's no definitive answers as to why
things change
so i'll start off with the first site
which is currion
there's a little google map and up in
the left there is an ancient
sanctuary site to a god of apollo and in
this case it's a deity of apollo called
apollo high lattes which is apollo of
the woodland so he's a nature deity of
apollo it's basically the worship of
you know
nature
fundamentally apollo is a god of of
strength
and represents strength in a lot of
things in this case in cyprus
he's a nature deity
um there's a city site to aquarium down
on the right i haven't shown that but
just there's a um an exercise
you know roman ruin there that you know
you could play sports in or whatever
just to give you a little sense of scale
so
this is
the temple of apollo high lattes
i did the restoration work on this
temple when i when i started work on it
the foundation
was about this high
when i came to the site
and over the course of about four years
i excavated stones i laid them out on
the ground
and i interpreted what the temple was
and the
after i left i actually all the stones
were laid out right on the ground right
right here next to the temple
and then a number of years after i left
they took all the stones and put them
back up vertically
the columns are um
new because we could we didn't have any
column shafts
in it but most of the other stones are
antique stones and the whole upper
segment of the temple
are the main stones that i joined and
put together none of that was known
until i did this work
so
so here's the here's the sanctuary site
the temple's at the top
and you can see how it's self-contained
within a forest and there's nothing
outside of that that sanctuary it was
really for roaming deer it was for
animals and that's how they really
looked at the world so
what's this really saying is is that
in ancient culture their value system
was correct
by by the art by how they worshipped by
what they built we knew that their value
system was correct in order to have a
successful society
the one other little aspect is there's a
little circle up there in the sanctuary
in the upper
left to medium upper left-hand area
when you find apollo you start looking
for daphne and
anybody read their daphne uh
their classics in terms of okay
that apollo chases daphne
when apollo touches daphne she turns
into an olive tree
so what you do is you start to look for
daphne
oh there's there was this unnaturally
flat area to the site
and i said to the archaeologist we
should just dig over here
and we found daphne's garden we found
evidence of of tree pits where trees
would have been planted a little
circular walkway so we actually
completely
mythology actually fits the site and the
greeks were great on this they just they
it was like a recipe
okay next site is ephesus
this is on the coast of turkey this is
the ionian coast of turkey ephesus was
the
like new york city of the ancient world
it was
commerce commerce commerce
and then all of a sudden ephesus
disappeared
from
being an important city
and what happened ephesus
the site's way over here where it says
efes that's
and then there's that little little
marsh right now in the modern google map
well that was your port
and that used to be connected to the
ocean
so
either the sea fell the land rose or
some sort of combination of siltation
happened there's multiple events going
on here and you have the death of a city
and this is equivalent in the ancient
world this is equivalent to new york
city this is not a small thing
so things went wrong
we're not totally sure
a lot of people go for the whole
siltation thing
i think the answer is more complex
it really can show you
the
amount of change that can happen to
geography
within 2000 years
so ephesus is a little map of the
ancient site this is a great site to go
to
um this is the the ancient library in
ephesus
and
at that time period
um
this would have been
essentially the stanford university of
the ancient world that's all the
knowledge of the world
was
this was one of the centers of the
knowledge of the world at that point in
time
now this is also the the theater at
ephesus and you really don't even see
the whole thing it keeps going up the
hillside
theaters are great because you can start
to scale the size of the city that you
should anticipate based on the size of
the theater it's like scaling the size
of stanford from your football stadium
you know there's a big university here
otherwise you wouldn't have a stadium
that big
so we use we use theaters as a telling
sign of of how big the culture was where
what they were really doing
this is a phenomenal theater you should
go see it sometime in your life you
should go to ephesus and see this
okay the third site this is a google
image of leptus this is on the the coast
of libya
and
i was really hoping things would go
differently in libya so we could all go
to
visit leptis
the beaches are great this is the
mediterranean coast at its best
but up in the middle of that picture
there's another silted in harbor the
ancient harbor is is that whole green
area up there
it's a similar story we see large
changes in mediterranean cities
and we really don't have all the answers
there's a theater way see that way up on
the left is the theater
and then way down on the right there's a
coliseum
and both are large so
we also know leptus was a was a was a
big
a big city
here's here's the theater
not as big as ephesus but
here's the stadium
and by the way all of our stadiums are
based off of roman stadiums they have
been for forever
this would have been a very lush climate
2000 years ago all trees
this is a very different
visual than what was there 2000 years
ago
okay now i'm gonna i'm gonna shift to
another point in time
and this is the year 1100
in the borders country between england
and scotland
that red dot up there
you know if you get in in the big map up
there that little red dots the borders
country
there was a lot of trade at that time
between belgium and this area and the
borders country in scotland
and
the four red dots on this little google
map here
are abby's
abbeys were the equivalent of a
like a small new england college
so you can get on your bicycle and ride
between these four small new england
colleges
the question is
why
how why in the year 1100
there's there's this level of
sophistication
and four colleges sitting in a place
where you'd never even think anything
was going on this is 200 years you guys
watch braveheart the movie
you know they're like you know he's
living in a mud hut
but this is actually 200 years
before
braveheart and the battles and those
braveheart battles were within 10 miles
of these dots
so the question we see
a rise in civilization in this very
specific way
and
you have to start to figure out well
what happens
what are all the key things is it the
climate
is it the people is it the wars how does
all of this
interact well this is one of the abbeys
this is melrose abbey it's a little plan
of it up there that's the remaining part
this is the the nave here and this is
the the main part that that uh
is built well
you know those braveheart guys
were a lot more advanced than what was
shown in the film is the bottom line
and
there was a very this is a very
important
center of culture at that point in time
this is jedburg abbey this is one of the
other ones
um this rivals in size what you would
find in paris um in the 1500s
inter in terms of create or in florence
if you go to florence or paris and you
see larger cathedrals they're largely
based on these earlier versions
out of england
and the abbeys were also
french they were
benedictine and
a whole bunch of different names
cisernians were there they were all
allied with friends sort of like a
you had a college out here but they
there was a main university down in
france or something they were all
talking to each other and trading
so what is this i mean this is like
jack's teaching art history here
and
so if you haven't ever taken art history
at this point i'm going to say you can
go to a class and you can spend all
semester looking at slides of
architectural history or art history and
you should do it because this is just a
little intro and it'll give you a very
good perspective
to look at our modern problems because
basically you're seeing the remains
of failed societies and then you can
start to contemplate what the problems
really are
so
what does this have to do with climate
change
okay this is a reconstructed temperature
graph i have no clue if it's accurate or
not but if we're way back here in
ancient times
you can see the theoretical temperatures
stead pretty level
right here at the year 1100
boom
the abbeys were built
what happened it warmed up in southern
scotland
so agriculturally that area took off
what happened
uh around 1200 this is when braveheart
it's starting to go downhill a little
bit
but by you know sixteen hundred those
abbeys are ruins they were ruins in
about fifteen hundred and they're gone
little ice age coming
the whole economy collapsed in this in
this part of um scotland
and it never recovered
now there are a lot of wars and things
like that there are a lot of
contributing issues but the question is
it is a direct evidence
of the effect of climate change and the
importance of of dealing with climate
change in a reasonable way
and then we have the graph here you know
we're just
heating up again
so
now i'm gonna i'm gonna switch over to
my my company as an architect
i've i've
created a little company
on how to build buildings
the the fundamental principle is
can we
drive buildings down
right now i'd say
electricity use buildings use like 47
of all electrical energy
can we drive the use of that energy
down so low
that
all the other technologies every
advanced technology you could think of
because you simply have to use less of
an advanced technology or an expensive
technology
is that a better solution to buildings
and it's it's the issue of of waste how
do we get waste out of the system we can
always come up
with systems
that
you know solve the problem of waste but
can we solve the problem of waste and
the root level and that's where my
company is is headed
we have a structural technology and a
thermal technology
so these four little blocks up there are
the structural technology
and they they're it's just a it's a
model idea
of interlocking blocks you can see those
blocks they have male corners female
corners everything interacts on every
axis
and if we consider the space between the
blocks to be a wall
you get a structural form of those four
blocks and i put a i actually made the
four blocks and then i put this really
loose
caulking in between which is just like
putty in your hands
but as soon as you do that you take a
soft material put it in there and you
can twist it and it all interlocks and
it's extremely strong
so this is what's referred to as a
composite structural solution
and
you're thinking
what's what are we trying to do with
this well what we're trying to do is
those blocks we want to be the size of
this room
then we can be inside of them
then what we want to do is we want to
take those blocks we want to stack them
up we want to make really tall buildings
and then we want to pour the concrete
last
well what have we done we've created a
reinforced concrete building with a
cellular structure
that
has no rebar
all the cost in building buildings every
building on campus here is just loaded
with rebar it's it's hand labor it's
everything we're trying to automate the
process of building we're trying to
build buildings in a different way
so i've got a little
little video
what would a presentation be without a
video
so we stack
boxes oh even get music here
and we pour the concrete in his glue
and then you have a build and i just
picked a historical building for this
but that's how we want to fundamentally
change building from a construction
process to a manufactured process
we want to change the structural
characteristics of the building and how
we build buildings
and and we can do all this this isn't
an issue of not being able to do it
if we think in new ways we can actually
do these things
so the other um
technology we have
is
when you we end up with a wall system
that looks like this with a little curvy
wall if i showed you this picture first
you say well no one's going to build a
little curvy wall
it would be like way too much labor but
when you invert
the build to big boxes
and then you get the curvy wall it's
really easy in fact it's easier to build
a little curvy wall
now straight walls are kind of lazy but
any curved form is always taught it's
strong it's like ready for stress
and that's really what the structural
aspect here is
the other technology we have is a
thermal technology
and if you look at this maybe the next
yeah i'll go in well
the thermal technology
is is that
how do we create walls that are have a
better insulation value for driving
energy use way way down how do we do it
everybody says oh just more insulation
well it's it's technically the wrong
answer
you know when the astronauts went to the
moon they didn't carry a lot of
insulation with them
they you know you didn't see them like
you know big you know doughboys out
there
you know they they actually had very
very thin layers of insulin insulation
and at that point nasa developed um
ideas on insulation
about radiant and convective and
conductive energy and dealing with all
of them and that's why the astronauts
survived up there we're essentially
doing the same thing the building
industry is slow
i'm here 30 years later saying
the building industry needs to adopt a
technology that nasa adopted and
promptly forgot
and then we're we're reimagining it for
buildings so what's the advantage here
to this little curvy wall you get all
these little airspace voids
if we do the right things with these air
spaces
we get a super insulation
the performance of this eight inch wall
is
over r60 i are anybody familiar with r
values it's a measure of heat transfer
through
building materials
the only problem is our values are
fantasy it's like visiting
the fiction section of the library
they're technically wrong they were
invented by the fiberglass industry
to
make fiberglass look good
and it just ignored radiant energy
totally
so
the the fundamental solution
is to
go to the next slide
is to create
little foil layers a little
blown in
it could be urethane insulation
anything
and to have little air spaces with foils
on both sides of a wall
and you get this superior
thermal performance r16 above if you
equivocated it to a bad scale
and
it works we've we've actually put it in
the number of of houses as as test beds
this is a foil on the outside it's a
special foil this is like a nano
deposited foil
but when you reject radiant energy early
you have a really good chance of having
extremely energy efficient buildings
so we're bringing both of these
technologies
to market
i'm there's a third technology sort of a
little derivative technology that we
developed
and
we took our box technology and we're
currently marketing to the dod because
they have a little containerized
buildings all over the world
when we wrap these buildings we wrap the
floor with the super insulation well the
number of buildings with a super
insulated floor
is approximately zero
it's very very rare they do in the
arctic but it's a different thing they
just lift the building way up
but what we realized is we did a super
insulated floor system put it down on
the ground the the ground source
geothermal energy down six feet which is
what geothermal heat pumps run off of
comes to the building it migrates right
to the building in about 30 days
so the dod
had never
even thought in fact you can read in
their things don't use
ground source geothermal heat pumps in
the desert or don't use them anywhere in
the world because you have to dig
trenches down six feet and we just sort
of raised our hand and said no you don't
if you create a building that is so
energy efficient
and the the thermal box that we're
proposing is seven times
more efficient
than what they have out there
and you put a source that's four times
more efficient on creating heat which
with a geothermal heat pump is
the
resultant building is a 28x improvement
over over what the dod has in place
overseas
then every piece of solar every piece of
anything you want to do becomes
affordable as a technology everybody's
worried about new technologies and how
to make them affordable what i'm saying
here is drive the demand into the floor
first
then every idea you guys come up with
is a economically viable thing to deploy
on buildings
oh this is a little 28x what is 28x
performance so
if we did it on a gallon of gas
and
the
old buildings
you see old clue
if you ran
just the efficient part of the building
for an hour the heating system you'd be
able to a gallon of gas and you'd keep
that building heated or cooled for 4.4
hours
the brand new clue
containerized building that the dod has
you get 8.8 hours and then our
containerized building you get 275 hours
yes
making the building more efficient
drives down the cost
you guys on the cost of making like you
know eating it up or whatever things
like that but that would also
like not just
help
sort of like you know renewable energy
but also like you know fossil fuel
consumption too so
that doesn't necessarily like you know
um you know that would necessarily like
you know be an advantage because
if if you could even like you know hit
your up dealing with call like you know
mm-hmm at the cheaper price dance i was
like oh well
so last time
but
i would that
incentivize someone going for renewable
as opposed to going for fossil fuel
sources
well
on the economic basis
driving demand down is the least costly
there are many studies on this
driving demand down is always the least
costly option
and i'm just saying do that first
so if you if you put everything back
into cost per kilowatt hour
you'll see that
energy
reduction
is the the best payback
to to be spent
and energy production
is
is the most expensive thing
but we have to do both we have to make
green energy we just have to consume it
you know
better
so let's see we have a little picture
these are some of the building designs
for the dod yes
two questions one is depending on the
size
of the kind of building blocks
how do you transport them
say it's like in a city how would you
actually transport
one of those building blocks yeah build
a house or something of that nature and
then the second question is really to
building stock and how quickly it turns
over and how the what the penetration
rate of this type of
building might be
i'll answer the second question first um
over the next 25 years we'll build one
third of our building stock
we've gone through a time recently where
rehabbing old buildings has been the
central focus and i will contend that
that will continue
but the new building is about to begin
in a in a very large way we will build a
lot the opportunities are really going
to be on new buildings
and um
your other question was the
transportation oh the transportation you
know there are guidelines on
transportation it's not it's not pretty
you just the bigger the box the more you
pay is is the issue you can get them
there
um the maximum box size might be about
12 by 12 by 64 feet
fortunately we can cut out all the sides
you can stack them up you can cut out
sides you can join them up so that you
get bigger spaces
but
from a market point of view we're
targeting
um condominiums and and those are highly
cellular building topologies
questions
you can pretty much
fully cut out all sorts of things in
other words if you took one of those
boxes and cut out half of it it would
still be
very very stiff
it's a structurally efficient form
factor here yeah
this is like you know just like tesla
has a factory over there
you know
we
we want a factory like that and we just
want to make big boxes and ship them and
build big build you know tall buildings
you know
yes uh what would be like the first
building that you'd like to see
like
would it be a hospital would it be an
office building would it be a
retail outlet like we'll be the first
like what does this most egg go for
right right
i'm for the low-hanging fruit
the first
we think the dod is going to be first
because they have a very ugly they're
running these bases off of diesel
generators so the equation for them
is
is really ugly we we gave them a life
cycle study a 25-year building life
cycle
study
capital and operating expense for our
base versus their exist their base
were half the cost total cost
we're half of what they're what our
government is currently spending
and so we think that's a compelling case
for them to go first but the dod sort of
have a time frame all of their own we
have no clue
when they're going to say yes
but they're interested
on the commercial side
we feel that
housing
probably senior housing
or affordable housing
or housing for the homeless are are all
going to be viable contenders for early
adoption it depends on how much pain the
governments are feeling
then the governments will say let's
build some net zero housing
and our our
current marketing is that on the
commercial basis our buildings will be
10 percent less to build
and they'll operate at about a 40
percent um cost savings versus existing
and so developers are really interested
in this but we do need governments to
say we want net zero
and we want grid free we want resilient
buildings we need the governments to say
this and the developers will just follow
but the governments have to say that
first
so i'm throwing up a little business
model slide
because
we can have all you know architects
we're great at ideas
we think of ideas all the time it's a
matter of bringing those ideas out into
the
you know the real world so we have a
business model here that that
our business is we virtually create our
buildings
and
then that virtual reality of the
building eventually because moves into a
factory
and
that factory then produces the
containers and they get transported and
we we build two things we build tall
urban net zero housing
for the commercial market
and we build net zero containerized
living units for the for the dod
we've identified three states as being
the growth areas in the countries
california texas and florida
and um
you know we're looking to get the
product out there and and and start yes
like how can you comply through some
other alternative to compliance or
materials like
it's
yes
we are building code compliant
not in our most sophisticated form
however in in the most basic forms we
can build under the codes today but as
an illustration i started to talk about
r values
when i first designed the thermal system
the r value
calculated out at r12 which is
non-compliant you have to be about r22
to be compliant
um
we
eventually
figured out how to get it to calc out at
about r26
and there's some
tables in the ashrae handbook that
nobody's looked at for decades that
allowed us to make that interpretation
legally and that's part of the code so
we we actually can fill out the forms
and comply but we're actually building
an r50 value
performance level
and
the california energy commission
actually recognizes that this is a
technical problem
because what it does is it devalues
our superior technology it's not
recognized for for its performance level
and that comes when you build buildings
and people aren't going to buy you say
oh it's going to be less to operate and
they're going to
they'll just say no you can't use that
figure
and then
once you devalue a technology it's
harder to get it adopted well the
california energy commission actually
put out a building envelope
grants application which we've applied
for we applied for it ourselves lawrence
livermore national laboratory and arab
engineers out of san francisco
to
study the physics of heat transfer in
buildings
and get away from the r-value system and
so we're prepared to we also went in
with the navy they gave us a site down
near death valley which is really really
hot
they have an air station down there
called china lake we found the most
extreme temperature location in
california and so we want to do a little
demonstration and build some buildings
model them do the physics work and then
hand that back over to the the energy
commission
and
so
yeah there's a there's a lot of yeah
uh
what type of foundations do you have to
build just for these buildings and also
what how long does it take to construct
them since they're already
modularized on the commercial we put a
on a standard foundation
um
under under the urban housing buildings
or 30-story buildings the the
idea for earthquake is called base
isolation where where the the structure
is highly cellular and rigid but the
whole building has a little
shift at the bottom
and um
but besides everything from that point
down is pretty pretty standard it would
be standard poor car we're interested in
everything
moving up in fact it would probably be
up one level a lot of urban buildings
want a big open space in in that first
level or the first two levels then we go
in into the smaller pieces up above
how long would it take
production yes um
we think our buildings are
about
um
a 30 savings in time
in a city and that's also a big deal for
governments if they value that their
street disturbance issues
all of that
we also
know that we can do
um
net zero buildings in an urban
environment
and
the
first phase of that is
to use combined heat and power
in in the mix of a building
and once you introduce
are you guys familiar with chp
once you introduce chp you could have a
pv building that's hyper efficient with
chp in the basement
pretty much you just have to bring a gas
line into the building you don't need to
bring an electrical line to that
building because the chp
can take care of your electrical loads
you know
i'll let the chp make their
those folks make they're right on the
edge of net zero or non-net zero if
illegally
i think they that industry has decided
they've they've convinced everybody that
they are net zero
but yeah you know i'm not going to
really defend that uh i'm just going to
say that's the early adoption stage
they'll be replaced by you know more
efficient
um
you know pv
um they'll be replaced by
flywheel power or something you know the
all of these technologies are in play
and we're just going to utilize whatever
the the most enabling technology
first
so i'm just just going to finish off on
on the temple and
and um
did anybody ever
you know i put out that you should go
read vincent scully's book if you don't
take an art history
course you should read this book the
earth the temple and the gods
it's really it's a it's a good read
it'll give you a really good perspective
on
on cultures and why we value the
environment what's the point of of
saving everything if we can't figure out
what we really value and that's that's
the we need to build the cities that we
can live in that our culture can thrive
in
and that we that we can value and that's
what the ancients um you know did and
they did it really really well is is the
issue we still
the architecture right there that they
invented
is a dominant form of architecture
everywhere you can see it all over your
campus you know little porticos it's the
greeks that's where it all came from
so any more questions or
do you have more questions for jack or
from the reading about sustainable
design some other examples that we had
um i i have a question
you you raised the
the issue of these disappearing cities
their
harbors had changed
went away
it looked like it could be possible to
have just changed their location of
where they were shipping from and
changed where their building was what
what was going on you've roamed around
there you must know when you when you
likened it to new york city you know
this is very relevant
on ephesus did change
they created a new port
10 miles away called kusadasi then that
city is still there that's still a big
thriving city okay so ephesus was
was such a a radical problem
that
they they actually created a new city
um
leptus
north africa didn't fare well
and so i think the climate change in
north africa was so radical you have a
whole series of cities the size of
leptus
and
you can go to places in north africa
with huge theaters
in the middle of nowhere and you say oh
my there must have been a big city here
and you don't see any evidence of it all
so i think north africa just baked it
lost its top soil lost its rain
and it just
just baked and it never came back so
here we sit in california with a
horrific drought going on yeah i mean
you're seeing that as part of what's
been changing yeah
does your
building
this was something i was thinking you
might have in mind
make things more resilient to climate
change and how certainly being net zero
is wonderful you're not making the
problem worse with more emissions but
are you more are your buildings more
likely to withstand
changes
yes
and how i'm
we're working with lawrence livermore
laboratory and they have the they're the
only place in the world that can model
buildings
for
destructive testing on their super
computers and they have written software
that just sits on their computers it
doesn't exist anywhere else
and you can make buildings
implode you can launch projectiles at
them you can put them in the worst storm
you would ever want you can do anything
you can put any force onto them
and they will analyze them at the atomic
level
of of destruction
and they're very interested in moving
the technology
that analysis technology out to market
they love our buildings because we're a
composite system
and so there's a lot of redundancy built
into cellular systems they they likened
us to a beehive that if you push on the
outsides the center stays stays good
and so it's it's it
they're just they want to
you know do a lot of analysis for us
it's exciting is this provoking any
further
questions thoughts
some of you were worried about smart
grid um do you
you have i mean you're you're i i have a
i have a
uh
opinion of the smart grid
um
i think um
islanding independent
buildings as a microgrid that that have
their own resiliency
is is the smartest thing to do
there are too many
um
factors
i mean you know that metcalf station was
was shot up a year and a half ago you
know
just south of san jose
and have you guys read about that the
yeah
okay it's a it's a substation
that was shot at just with
with a bunch of guns
and the substation almost went down if
it did go down there would have been a
blackout in the entire bay area
it didn't quite go down
and that's not resiliency at all it's
just exposure
and we have to we have to reimagine how
we're doing things so that the buildings
themselves have um
have resiliency
and
autonomous function and independence is
is a key issue i have no problem with
the grid being there and everything but
it's not the only solution
if you make that grid really really
smart
it still has exposure on a physical
level and what i'm saying is
let's create and the technologies are
very easy to to for things to be
islanded stanford has its own little
power system right here
i'm sure they could
you know if
metcalf went down stanford would just be
humming right along they just they just
disconnect from the outside grid
and so that those are very important uh
technologies to have
going back to the durability of building
um we talked about like you know
withstanding physical and um
physical like climate conditions about
um
sort of like you know chemical
conditions like maybe acid and things
like that because like as emissions
increases and things like that how could
how would that affect the
chemical integrity of the building
yeah you know
let me answer that in a broader one of
the things i advocate is
i've showed you ancient civilizations
that radically changed when carbon
wasn't moving around
everybody's like blaming carbon you know
they're like oh carbon's going up every
you know the the world's gonna
you know
whatever it's it's not the only reason
it's what i want to say
i think there are there are a hundred
reasons why temperatures are going up
and we don't even think about all of
them
and i'm i fully believe carbon's a a big
big picture thing here but i think
there's a lot of other things going on
that we don't know about
and we have to broaden our minds
to say we shouldn't be
creating a society that is taking
unnecessary risks in unknown
ways because it's going to come back to
haunt us we're we'll solve the carbon
thing and then the temperature still
goes up we don't know that it could
so maybe we have to solve the carbon
thing and three other things
in order for to
i'll agree that there are amplifiers
like the you know melting ice then
further exacerbates things so yeah it's
certainly certainly true and i just want
i just want to
these societies
all perished
and carbon wasn't a factor
well they're cooking over fires who
knows what they were inhaling i'm not
sure you know you know
probably just shorten their lifestyle or
something you know it's a different
effect of carbon they just you know
something like that
yeah thank you any other questions for a
speaker
let's thank you very much
you